he is the nfl chief medical officer dr
alan sills back on the program doc
thanks for joining us how are you today
hey i'm doing great dan thanks for
having me back is the nfl player
safer in the bubble or in camp
than the average citizen is
i would say yes dan because i think when
we're in our camps and our facilities we
obviously have
extensive protocols that cover every
aspect of what we're doing
so we've put a tremendous amount of
thought and energy and effort as you
know together with the players
association and creating the safest
possible environment so i think when you
combine our screening
our testing program all the
interventions we've put in place at our
facilities the way we've reimagined the
day
i would say yes people are much safer in
that environment than they would be
out working out in some other
environment what has changed since the
last time we talked
well i think we continue to learn from
the experience of other sports and just
where the virus is going in general you
know we've seen for example the cdc
change some of their guidance about how
we clear people and bring them back
we've learned more about persistent
positive tests and how people can test
positive for a very long time so
we're learning literally every day and
certainly every week
but i think what hasn't changed is you
know our commitment to being very very
diligent in every aspect of what we do
and i think i think there's also an
increasing recognition on the part of
all of our players coaches and staff
this is something we're going to have to
do every single day
we got to be consistent and we can't let
our guard down because as soon as we let
our guard down that's when bad things
can happen to us
as individuals and to teams to the
league as a whole what sport have you
learned the most from
well that's a tough one you know what
we've learned from everybody i think
because we've been in contact not
just with uh north american sports but
around the world we've talked a lot with
australian football
with world rugby with the bundesliga
with the english premier league so so i
think everyone has contributed to our
knowledge
and certainly i continue to communicate
regularly with my colleagues in the nhl
and major league baseball and the nba
and mls and i got to say dan
probably one of the gratifying things
about this is you look at
silver linings it's been the level of
cooperation and collaboration among all
the leagues
because this isn't you know one team
against the other or one league against
the other this is all of us against this
virus
and so we've had more communication
collaboration than we've ever had which
has been i think a very positive thing
and something that'll make
us all better i know that you have to
look at what if scenarios
and i always start with the worst case
scenario and then work my way back
let's say you have an outbreak like the
miami marlins had
what what is protocol
well we look at those cases very
carefully we look at it together with
players association with our infectious
disease advisors and we take whatever
the safest steps are so
you know we've said that all options are
on the table uh including
missing games or or more than one game
if necessary but i think what you have
to look at is each case is unique it
depends on how many people
are infected um the time course
a lot of factors about that host city so
it's hard to give you an algorithm and
say well it's this number or this number
but clearly we recognize that we're
going to have to be flexible and
adaptable throughout the whole season
and we'll have to respond to these
challenges as we come up and whatever we
do
we're going to make the best decision
that's in the interest of safety of
everyone involved
players coaches staff and our fans as
well what troubled me with the marlin
situation doctor
is that you had the team voting on
playing a game on sunday after four
players had tested positive so
they they had a team member
a player making this decision and i'm
wondering about with the nfl
can you have a neutral a third
a neutral party or somebody who's not
with the organization who reports to you
who's able to make these calls if a
situation like that arises
yeah well i can't obviously speak to the
specifics of that situation dan but i
would just say what we envision is if we
had a situation arising with positive
test results
obviously that gets immediately reported
to the league to the players association
and that would be a league determination
so again
i and my staff conjunction with the
players association medical staff our
infectious disease experts
we put all our heads together and make
what we think is the best decision in
real time
any changes in the equipment you talked
about a a face mask
shield last time we talked where do we
stand on that
yeah we're still evolving that so um our
we're to the level now where players are
back in camp and they can actually use
it and so we've distributed those across
all our clubs
we're going to have players using them
actively and giving feedback to the
design
engineers and so i think you'll continue
to see that product evolve and change
and we'll get to you know subsequent
versions of it so we're still very
excited about the idea we think it will
have a place on the field
and so uh we'll see as players use it
more as they're getting into their camps
we're excited to kind of see where that
whole project goes what about wearing a
mask
as we have to do in everyday life can a
football player perform while wearing a
mask
or do you have modifications to that
mask for players
yeah again we've worked on a lot of
different designs they're sort of the
neck gator type design that you that you
can pull up that you've seen some people
use as a face covering i mean we've had
some players that have worn those in the
league over the past few years if you've
seen that you know in the pre-covered
era
so i think you'll see some players
wearing that there are obviously other
mask options and at the end of the day
again i think you're going to see
players
adapt a lot of these different tools to
to increase their margin of safety
certainly you're going to see everybody
else in and around the sideline game
officials
and every time someone's not on the
field performing they're going to be in
mass
because i think we've all learned one
thing masks work
they are absolutely key and they're
they're very essential to preventing
transmission of this disease
so really it's not an exaggeration to
say the more time we spend in masks and
the more people we get in masks the
better off we're all going to be
but there's no mandate to have mask on
players
when they're practicing or in games we
haven't reached that point of agreement
yet with players union i think it's
we'll see where this design takes us and
if we can get to a design we all feel
comfortable we might revisit that idea
but as of today no there's no mandate
there does the nfl want that
you know dan i'm looking at everything
that makes us safer so i i would
certainly hope that we arrive at a
design that offers protection and
doesn't hinder performance and i think
if we do that it would certainly be
something
i'd want to see everyone adopt um and
and i think if we can hit that sweet
spot if we can find something that does
offer protection and does not hinder the
way that guys breathe or communicate on
the field
i have to believe the players would buy
into that and they would want that
because at the end of the day they want
to be safe as well
and if we can do that in a way that
doesn't hinder their performance i
believe it's something they'll all want
to be a part of
what team do you root for
that's a loaded question you know uh i i
always say dan it's a little bit like
your children you know you love all your
children some are easier to love than
others but uh
but no uh no no favorites uh i i'm just
uh grateful to have the chance to work
with all of them and really appreciative
and let me say this all kidding aside
the amount of work that our teams have
put into getting ready and opening these
training camps
it's just phenomenal we've seen every
level of the staff
just completely reimagine and redo their
facilities and i've talked one-on-one i
talk with head coaches every day
i mean these are obviously people who
are not usually wanting to change things
they've gone in and completely changed
everything about their building and
about the way they practiced so
i just tipped my hat to the work that's
gone on and we know there's a lot more
work in front of us it's gonna be really
hard
but i'm excited to to see where this
takes us thank you doc
maybe privately you'll tell me uh who is
your favorite football team
hey i can give you a college team how
about that will we go there sure why not
well you can see behind me i'm a
mississippi state grad so uh so i'm a
bulldog through and through we'll go
with that as my favorite
all right sounds good thank you doc we
appreciate your time
hey thanks for having me dan have a
great day that's dr alan sills the nfl
chief medical officer
and neurosurgeon